[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui
je vais vous apprendre
à manager
car il est beaucoup plus difficile à
prendre a managé cage anglais
ma passion pour le jonglage m'est venue
à l'âge de 10 ans
il ya vingt ans j'ai réalisé mon rêve je
suis devenu artiste au sein de la
compagnie alexis gruss
acrobates jongleurs cavaliers danseurs
sur corde en équilibre à 4 mètres de
hauteur jeu rebondissait sur cette corde
élastique
et le 20 février 2002
moi aussi je suis tombé
une blessure si grave que je ne pourrai
plus jamais remonté sur cette corde
une première leçon
comment rebondir après un tel
traumatisme
sur mon lit d'hôpital
j'ai rassemblé ce qu'il me restait
d'énergie
de courage
et d'optimisme
et j'ai créé mon entreprise
je me suis spécialisé dans la prévention
des risques
un comble
en réalité ce qui m'a toujours passionné
ce sont les rapports humains
c'est formidable tout ce qu'on arrive à
faire avec un collectif
tout ceci j'ai appris grâce au jonglage
et aujourd'hui j'aimerais partager avec
vous quelques notions indispensables aux
managers jongleurs
car en entreprise aussi en jambes
avec les projets avec les talents avec
les émotions même apprendre à jongler
c'est apprendre
à ne jamais laisser tomber
une véritable école d'humilité et de
persévérance
d'adaptation aussi
merci pour le cadeau
c'est souvent ce qu'on dit quand on
recrute c'est vrai moi j'étais là
tranquille avec mes deux collègues qui
on balance quelqu'un comme ça sans me
demander mon avis
ça vous parle
on a souvent tendance à recruter des cd
plutôt que des compétences ou des
talents au risque de se tromper sur ce
recrutement
je vous parle même pas du fameux août on
a cinq balles qu'on cherche toujours un
contrôle jamais
imaginé un instant que l'on mette toute
l'énergie le temps et l'argent que l'on
met sur le recrutement plutôt au profit
de l'accompagnement des salariés une
fois dans l'entreprise on y gagnerait
toutes et tous
d'autant que le mouton à cinq balles si
par miracle on le trouve on prend aussi
le risque de mettre la pagaille dans ses
équipes
recrutés sur un cv c'est tout misé sur
le passé rien sur l'avenir
chaque fois que j'ai recruté je me suis
dit
si les personnes en face de moi
connaissez mon cd
jamais illustré demi heure d'entretien
vous iriez vous vous faire embaucher par
un ancien clown
du coup je me suis toujours attaché à
faire ressortir la vraie personnalité
des gens en entretien
savez vous combien il ya de bars à tapas
à madrid
c'est une question que je posais souvent
en entretien
et là vous avez trois types de réactions
la personne qui se décompose
littéralement
la personne qui vous sort un chiffre
venu de nulle part
et puis la personne qui vous dit
laissez-moi cinq minutes et un
ordinateur je vous donne le bon chiffre
en réalité ce n'est pas la réponse qu'on
intéresse c'est le comportement et la
réaction de la personne
ne recruter pas les individus pour ce
qu'ils ont été mais pour ce qu'ils vont
devenir avec nous
maintenant qu'on a recruté il va falloir
manager et là tout se complique car il
n'y a pas une ni deux ni trois méthodes
mais autant que de salariés dans
l'entreprise et de jours dans l'année
et c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
je vous prendre un exemple
j'ai ici trois partenaires cette balle
qu'on appellera mon partenaire classique
et il en faut
cette boule de pétanque c'est mon
partenaire costaud fonceur lui il veut
toujours aller de l'avant
et c'est tough
c'est mon partenaire fragile et lui il
faut absolument pas le laisser tomber
et observez bien il y a une parfaite
harmonie une parfaite cohérence dans le
mouvement global tout simplement parce
que je m'adapte aux spécificités de
chacun au profit du projet collectif
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça les rapports humains c'est au
manager de s'adapter à chaque
individualité
tenez vous
bien
je vous avais dit qu'il était fragile
vous l'avez rattraper le manager assume
et ne laisse tomber personne
manager c'est également embarqué ses
équipes dans un projet en y mettant de
la passion et pour cela il va falloir
donner du sens à ce projet avec des
objectifs clairs dans lesquelles chacune
et chacun doit se retrouver
bien souvent on oublie d'expliquer
pourquoi on prend telle décision
pourquoi on va dans telle direction au
risque d'avoir des problèmes à rattraper
ou des sceptiques à remobiliser en
jonglage c'est pareil je ne peux pas
essayer de rattraper chaque balle c'est
trop compliqué je dois m'appliquer à
bien lancée je lance bien je rattrape
bien viser juste et au bon moment puis
au pire si un problème
grâce à la résilience on arrive toujours
à rebondir
à
la résilience c'est comme la
bienveillance ça ne se décrète pas c'est
pas un filet de vinaigre balsamique qu
on saupoudre comme ça autour de
l'assiette ça se travaille et tous les
jours d'autant que si on peut être
résilient une fois deux fois à la
troisième on ne rebondira pas
le manager jongleurs doit anticiper
planifier puis se lancer tout en gardant
une part de disponibilité pour gérer les
aléas car des imprévus il y en a tout le
temps parfois il peut y avoir des
tensions dans un groupe voire des
scissions et là il va falloir être
capable d'isoler une personne voire de
s'en occuper spécifiques
tout en gardant de la disponibilité pour
les autres
bien souvent on met 90 % de notre
énergie à gérer les 10% de personnes qui
posent problème au détriment des 90 %
qui sont exemplaires
le manager jongleurs doit donner du sang
à ces projets et faire preuve de
cohérence
et si on remet tout le monde dans le
même sens
il ya de fortes chances que ensemble on
atteigne nos objectifs
à ses applaudissements
c'est le privilège d'avoir son client ça
soit le public
ça vous donne envie d'en faire encore
plus ça vous met en confiance
et puis on a deux mondes
puis il va falloir anticiper et moins
à
soucy
donc je vous explique en fait ce qui
s'est passé là c'est pas de ma faute
il y à notre quai account manager jean
pierre
qui devait m'envoyer par mail les capi
haye
et puis bah a eu un problème
informatique
et la balle
elle est restée dans la boîte d'envoi
en fait vous en moquez nous explication
ce que vous voulez c'est que je
recommence ça recommence
envoyez j'ai pas triché j'ai assumé
et j'ai réussi
[Applaudissements]
et je suis sûr que vous avez même eu
envie d'applaudir deux fois plus tout
simplement parce que j'ai su gérer mon
échec je dirais même que ensemble nous
avons transformé un échec en réussite
collective
le manager assume et ne triche pas
pour résumé les principales qualités que
doit avoir le manager jongleurs il doit
savoir
recruter pour les bonnes raisons
s'adapter à chaque individualité
donner du sens à ces projets
ne pas tricher
et surtout
ne jamais laisser tomber
merci
[Applaudissements]